he's been known as a as a transphobe
he's been known as a homophobe oh he's
been known as a misogynist
the man the myth the legend doing work
that most people are too coward to do
today subhanallah miller got him rolling
stone new york times
they've been slamming him without even
watching it i think that's unfair so
let's see for ourselves bismillah
and sex and there's a lot of
controversies there if we're talking
about a trans woman has all of the male
physical characteristics so would that
not be
a male then couldn't we plainly say
this person is a male well well i guess
it's like
why are you asking the question i think
i i want to understand sort of why
that's so important so if someone tells
you to
sort of understand
reality
you know
well i mean i think when someone tells
you who they are you should believe them
so if a person says that they're a woman
or they're a man then that's them
telling you their gender is i'm not so
sure why what social um
interactions would have to do with with
maleness or femaleness that we've i'm
not even talking about social context
i'm just i'm just trying to start by
getting to the truth you know
yeah i mean i'm really uncomfortable
with that language of like getting to
the truth again in social life why is
that uncomfortable because that it
sounds actually deeply transphobic to me
um
and if you keep probing we're gonna stop
the interview i if i probe about what
the truth is you keep invoking the word
truth which is condescending and rude
i'm saying to you how is the word truth
kind of sending a root
why don't you tell me what your truth is
and you're walking on 30 seconds more of
the nights before i get up
what my truth is well i don't think i
really have a truth i think that there's
just the truth
like the reality
and so
we should begin by trying to figure out
what the reality is
uh-huh and why are you concerned with
when someone else tells you that they're
a man or even if they use the word male
why are you concerned with not believing
them
well you keep bringing it back to you
know how do you respond in a social
situation that's what i do i'm a social
scientist well right but we're in a
university this is a place of
understanding truth isn't it or
absolutely we pursue the truth and i'm a
social scientist and that's what i do
you just said the truth is transphobic
that you would say that you're if you're
saying the truth is that i get to say
you're not a man show me your genitalia
that's transphobia no i don't want to
see him as genitalia i i just mean
someone can make a statement about
themselves that could be untrue like for
example if i
if i were to say that i'm a black man
could you
would you accept that or would you be
skeptical
are you black are you afraid of american
are you biracial wow
why are you kidding so well you don't
look that and i don't think that's a
that it doesn't sound like that's a
genuine statement of who you are
okay so that's my point i could make a
statement about who i am that's
incorrect
of course i think it's well established
that human beings can lie yes
or not even lie i mean i could just be
mistaken
yeah
uh
i guess this all comes back just cause
it's all comes down to really one
question
especially
women
gender and sexuality studies
so what so what
what is a woman
why do you ask the question
i just really like to know
what do you think the answer that
question is
well i'm i'm asking that's why i came to
a college professor dude because
this is your this is what you do
what other kinds of answers have you
gotten look at his body language getting
closed
a lot of like this where you're not
answering i've got a lot of that so i
think it's interesting that you that you
say that some of the people you've
you've interviewed have been i'm
reluctant to answer it and i think that
has a lot to do with the way the
question guys listen i'm sorry for the
zoom ins bro i just had to when i was
editing
i got to see that one more time bro
[Laughter]
you've um interviewed have been i'm
reluctant to answer it and i think that
has a lot to do with the way the
questions that preceded it and the way
that you've conducted yourself in the
interview how have i conducted myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself
you just really don't answer the
questions do you
i came today very willing and
enthusiastic about answering questions
about women's and gender sexuality
studies which is so you wanted to do you
wanted to answer questions about women's
studies and so shouldn't the the first
answer you should be able to provide is
what exactly is a woman well it's it for
me it's it's actually a really simple
answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as as a woman
what is that
as a woman
do you know what a circular definition
is
i do
it's sort of like what you're doing
right now or a woman is a woman
because you're seeking what we would
call in my field of work an essentialist
definition of gender i think it sounds
like you would like me to give you a set
of biological or cultural
characteristics that are associated with
one gender or the other i'm not seeking
any type of definition i'm just seeking
a definition yeah and i gave you one
well now i can say i've been to college
oh my god we should get someone to
analyze everything what he was saying
the body language and just completely
break it down
um i don't think you need to be an
expert we don't need to be an expert to
do that but what i found profound guys
is
the hypocrisy between
the first thing
this
man i said
that i'm even calling that
if someone tells you they're a woman you
should believe them
contrast that with i don't believe it's
a genuine statement that you're black
why
why why do you have an issue accepting
that he's he's black
yeah
if they look like a man but they say
they're a woman we should believe that
sure yeah then if they look like a
five-year-old and they want to go after
a five-year-old girl you should believe
that yeah where do you draw the line
again something you notice about this
interview again is is the whole notion
of truth he brings it up matt walsh
brings it up a lot and they always
respond with
this kind of you could see the cognitive
dissonance you could see how frustrated
they're getting because it's kind of
like you know imagine i
i make a a a reality for myself right
i'm a blue pill guy i make a fantasy
world for myself where i'm like um an
astronaut and a doctor and a musician
and i mean this haram you know akari and
all these amazing things and someone
comes and they're like listen you're
none of those things like where's your
credentials let me hear you say quran
all of a sudden i start getting angry
like cognitive dissonance because
they're breaking apart my fantasy
because it's not the reality it's you
know i'm waking up to the hak i'm waking
up to the truth and it's a very
detestful if that's a word feeling right
obviously no one would like that you
could see it with these people it's so
sad these are our medical experts these
are doctors these are professionals and
this is how they're conducting
themselves
it just goes to show like these people
they um
they want to be right
so bad
hmm
you know like as as muslims
if we are not right and we are corrected
it's like okay you know like or if we
have no idea what we're talking about
we're like look like i just don't sure
we don't know you know like let me let
me
give you the information from someone
who does know
right we we don't try to
um put up this front but that's what you
see these people doing all the time
is they're putting up this front they're
trying to say like
that this is what it is one clearly it's
not and then when they're questioned
about it they get defensive like romney
said the cognitive dissonance
but then it's also like their ego is
like no like we have
we have to be correct like we have to
stay on this
in whatever way shape or form we can so
um it's just it's dangerous bro it's
pathetic
i wanna i wanna use that example of the
billionaire please donate just to show
how funny it is because this is actually
what they do you know i comment i'm a
billionaire and like show me your bank
account show me your billions i'm like
what do you mean why would i need
billions of dollars to be a billionaire
i'm a billionaire he's like well what is
a billionaire it's a billionaire
okay but what is it it's a billionaire
it's like show me billions like i don't
need to have billions of dollars to be a
billionaire but i'm a billionaire that's
exactly what they are doing
yeah
let me let me let me bring that up
actually you know what you guys already
seen this you can remind it if you want
in your free time but basically that's
what that man was saying what is a woman
someone who identifies as a woman what
is that a woman what is that a woman
like bro
you got ovaries you got an x and a y
chromosome
you got a vahivahi down there
i'm trying so hard not to be a child me
too and that makes you a woman bro
that makes you a woman is it that hard
to say bro
your son comes to you bro and tells you
he wants to be a girl he feels like a
girl what do you say
all right bro hey let me get you this
dress let's paint your nails bro and
let's let's go to school bro go like
that let's see how you feel probably
ashamed
actually society would love that they
call that gender affirmation yes yeah i
can't even say that
can't even say that bro
you can't even be sarcastic could we
possibly see matt walsh on the podcast
i'd love to ask him why he's still
christian because if he has an open mind
let's talk about some stuff
you know bismillah next question bro
i can't see okay so brother ben ekra
writes salaam guys have you looked into
using obs for your streams instead of
streamyard this will be our last live
stream
not forever
but for a while
because we are switching over to
professionally recorded
uh episodes podcasts inshallah
editors uh multiple angles all that
they're pre-recorded they're not gonna
be live anymore and they're gonna start
next week on friday insha'allah july 1st
2022 y'all are gonna get fresh new
podcasts every single friday so no more
of these live streams anyway so
inshallah you'll get good production
quality not just you know lighting like
this where it's just getting it done for
the podcast inshallah